MALE SPEAKER: So after we
graduated from Monta Vista High
School in Cupertino,
Erez is continued on
to get his Ph.D. in computer
science from UC San Diego.
So afterwards, while
the peers continued on
to research and full-time gigs
at Google, Microsoft, and up
and coming startups, he
decided to go the other route.
So stick to his story and
continue building guitars.
10 years ago, while Erez was
an up and coming luthier,
we were driving up north
from Southern California
with his first two guitars
that he built. And he didn't
have any power tools back then.
He was intending on gifting
one to his guitar teacher.
And I had to take the other one.
I fell in love with it,
it sounded beautiful.
So we were his first two
customers, basically.
And here we are 10 years
later inspired so many others.
Erez and myself continue
playing instruments
and appreciate
fine craftsmanship.
So please join me in giving
a warm welcome and a big hand
to luthier Erez
Perelman, my friend.
EREZ PERELMAN: Hey,
thank you so much,
[? Baris, ?] and
everyone here decided
to take time from their work.
This is probably a little
bit different from what
you guys are used to.
So if I feel privileged
to be here, and I hope you
guys will find it interesting.
The talk, we titled it Art,
Music, and Engineering.
In a way, it's how
I feel about myself.
Just three different
spaces that got
grouped together
into what you're
going to see in front
here, the guitar,
which is what I focus
my life on today.
So let's get started.
[? Baris ?] already
mentioned it.
I got a Ph.D. in
computer science.
My advisers actually
recently joined Google,
so I'm actually seeing
a few of my colleagues
from university
years, which is nice.
And that was 10 years ago.
So let me get started with what
we're going to discuss today.
We're going to talk about
my evolution briefly.
How I got into making guitars.
Then we're going
to briefly discuss
the history of the guitar, it's
a very interesting instrument.
And then we're going to get down
to the nitty gritty of making
the guitar, what goes into
it, materials, construction
methods, working
with hands, things
that are different from being
in the computer, really.
And at the end, I really want
to leave time for questions.
And also I have a client of
mine, he's a fantastic player.
This whole talk I'd
organized very last minute,
and asked him if he could do
a little video demonstration.
Because he has a flamenco
guitar and a classical guitar.
So we got a little treat
from a great player.
I'm going to include that
at the end of the talk.
OK, let's start with my journey.
As a young kid, I always
loved working with my hands.
My father did everything
with his hands.
Built furniture and
things like this.
My grandfather was
a sculptor, teacher
and he had a small, tiny
little workshop in his house,
and I loved spending
hours there.
And as a young kid,
I used to just take
chunks of wood I found on
the ground and start hacking
in with knives and chisels.
And here's one of
the creations I made.
I think this is when I was
12 or 13, it's a little owl.
That was my first passion.
A little bit later, I
got into guitar playing.
I was trained with
music from much earlier,
but I wasn't in love with
it until I found the guitar.
And then I really
fell in love with it.
And I dedicated a huge amount
of my time to practice,
and furthering myself.
And I actually ended up
choosing my university
based on the guitar teachers
that were there on the faculty.
They were [? Marrows, ?]
which was UCSD.
They're no longer teaching
through there now,
but I had the privilege
of studying with them even
though it wasn't my degree.
My degree was Computer Science,
which I continued as long as
possible to get my Ph.D.
And during my studies
in the university, even though
I was playing guitar a lot
and I was continuing
sculpting, I still
felt like I was missing using
my hands to create stuff.
And I had this longing to
build guitars for a long time.
And I contacted a few
guitar builders in the area,
and there are even schools
that you can go to.
But they're very expensive,
and I didn't have much money.
So I found a book
about building guitars.
I read it, and then
I just went for it.
I set up a tiny
workshop in my bedroom,
and I started building
my first guitar.
And it took me a year to do.
It was very
challenging, because I
had to make a lot of
the tools from scratch.
But it was a
interesting journey,
which started me on this
lifelong endeavor, really.
So I forgot to mention
the definition.
What I do, building musical
instruments that are stringed,
it's called a luthier.
Lutes are if you've
ever seen egg shaped
instruments, lots of strings.
Guitars, violins, cellos.
That's the family of
what luthiers build.
I focus specifically on
classical and flamenco guitars.
The picture you're
seeing here in this slide
is something for
my research, which
I thought would be
humorous to understand
what I used to study.
It was basically trying to
characterize the behavior
of programs as they execute.
Here we're looking
at [? GZip ?] and try
to classify them into faces.
And one thing you discover
when you start doing this
is that a lot of that behavior
is repetitive and cyclical.
And I find that applies to
my life, and many in general.
Where I started with
sculpting and playing
guitar and
engineering, and then I
went back to my roots of working
with my hands and sculpting.
And I still utilize
a lot of my research,
as you'll see some
of these slides.
So let's get into a
brief history of guitar.
Guitar, the earliest
predecessors
are actually quite ancient, from
Asia thousands of years ago.
But one distinction
about these instruments
is that they were carved
out of a block of wood.
The body of it.
So you took a log or
a big piece of wood
and just start hacking
at it, creating a cavity.
And you glue a
soundboard over that.
And you could still
have frets back then.
These were usually made
out of tendon or something,
and they're tied
around the neck.
And this is really the
earliest form of guitar.
But we start talking about
used instruments today,
we go into the
[? biwela. ?] That's
the true old guitar starting
from the Renaissance
and Baroque periods.
And in this instrument,
what we have
is a body that's created
from thin plates of wood
that were actually bent to
create the form of the sides.
The back was glued on, and
it's much, much lighter
than an instrument that was
carved out of a chunk of wood.
Acoustically, it behaves
much different in how
it vibrates and responds to
the attack on the strings.
So this is really where
we start seeing things
that sound more like guitars.
Now a couple centuries ago,
we have the romantic guitar.
And it's looking a lot closer
to what guitars look like today.
You see it's a
little bit narrower.
Main guitarists at
the time they used
it, Fernando Sor and Giuliani.
They're like the
Mozart of the guitar.
These are the instruments
that they used.
But the biggest evolution
of the instrument
was done when a Spaniard
by the name of Antonio
Torres in the 1850s designed
the guitar that we know today.
OK, this is the modern
classical guitar.
There was no
distinction back then,
it was just the Spanish guitar.
The body was much wider, and
some very interesting things
were done internally with the
bracing and the scale length
to give you the instrument
that we know today.
So Antonio Torres is
the father of the guitar
very much like
Antonio Stradivarius
is the father of the violin.
And not too much has been
changed as far as the looks
of the guitar goes.
Technologically,
though, there have
been some modern
evolutions of the guitar.
And if there's time
we'll get into that
at the end of the talk.
So let's get into the
construction of it,
or my approach.
That's the important thing.
The approach to how
do you build a guitar?
Well, there's a difference
when you first do it
and you just want to build
a guitar for yourself,
and when you do
it professionally
and you build it to
sell it to a client.
So now, I have orders.
People come to me.
They don't have to be
professional musicians,
but a lot of times they are.
And I need to understand
very, very specifically what
their needs are.
And this varies across a
huge spectrum of parameters.
For example, there can be
someone with smaller hands,
and it's very difficult for them
to play a standard size guitar.
So they may need modifications
in the length of the scale,
or the width of the neck,
and these are all things
that I can change and I
can control as a luthier.
Another needs are, for example,
the sound of the instrument.
There are people who like
to play classical music,
and there are people who
like to play flamenco music.
And there is a bit of a
difference in that sound.
The video later in the
talk will demonstrate that.
But all this has a
huge impact on how
I approach the
building of the guitar
before I even do
anything with the wood.
Once I understand the
needs of the clients,
the next thing, of course,
is to select the materials.
The materials that I choose will
have a very significant impact
on the sound of the instrument.
So I brought a guitar here
today that I recently finished.
This guitar is built with
a soundboard made out
of western red cedar.
This is darker than the spruce.
Spruce is the more
traditional wood.
It's a little bit
lighter in color.
This wood come to Canada, the
spruce comes from the Alps.
The body of this guitar
is made out of rosewood.
This is rosewood from
India, and there's
rosewood from South America,
there's rosewood from Africa.
If I choose different
materials for the guitar,
it will have an
impact on the sound,
as well as how I
treat that material.
So one of the important
things at the beginning
is to select the
material specifically
for the client's needs.
What kind of guitar
do they need?
I brought a few pieces
I'd like to pass around.
This is actually cedar
like you see on the guitar
here from the top.
This is very light, it's
considered a soft wood.
And it's light but stiff.
So pass this around,
has a nice smell.
This is a piece of cocobolo.
This is actually from Mexico.
The guitar I made
for [? Baris ?]
is built out of this wood.
It's extremely dense,
extremely oily.
Has a very glassy sound,
you guys can tap it.
And right here we have ebony.
This wood is not colored
or dyed in any way,
this is the natural
color of the wood.
This is from Africa.
It's a very, very
hard, dense wood.
If you put it in water,
it would actually sink.
And we use this in the guitar
where the fingerboard is,
because this is where the
fingers touch raw wood,
and you want it to withstand
the wear and tear of that.
So I'll pass this
around, and cocobolo.
So I select the
materials I'm going
to use for the guitar I'm
building for a specific client,
and then I start building it.
That's the construction process.
The materials-- I'll
ask you guys a question.
One of the most important
materials in the guitar.
It's up here, it's ridiculous
to ask the question.
The wood is the most
important thing.
But just as important is the
glue, and then the polish.
These three things are
what build a guitar.
You glue together two
pieces of wood with glue.
And a lot of people think,
huh, glue, very simple.
But actually, glue is a very,
very complicated medium,
material, whatever
you want to call it.
Well, adhesive.
But the different types of
glues have a huge impact
on the quality of sound.
Some glues that are, let's say,
soft and plasticy or foamy,
there are glues like that.
Like polyurethane
glues that foam up.
What happens, for
example, contact cement
is very soft also.
When you got two
plates vibrating,
it's going to dampen the sound.
Is going to absorb the
sound, and it's not
going to transfer
between the two pieces.
Versus a glue that's very
hard and crystallized,
which I'll talk
about in a second.
Which would actually transfer
the sound and the vibrations
without absorbing it.
The same goes for the polish.
I put huge thought and
labor into the polish
of an instrument, and
these three things really
make a big difference in the
quality of the instrument.
And finally, the
construction method.
There's two things
here, which is
the design of the construction.
Your traditional instrument.
Dimensions, the bracing that
goes into the instrument.
And then how you do it.
How do you tool the work?
So here is one angle
of my workshop today.
You see some guitars in the
background, they're hanging,
I'm polishing them.
You see here some
sound boards that
are already joined, and
just drying and seasoning.
And I work on this workbench.
This is where I spend
my day, I usually
stand there and do something
interesting with the wood.
Here, I'm slicing a
big chunk of wood,
this is going to be shown
later, how I make the necks out
of this material.
This is Spanish cedar.
Quite different from
the Western red cedar,
because this material
comes from South America
and it's much harder and
denser than the cedar
used for the sound boards.
The tools.
So the tools that
luthiers use today
are tools that used
to be widespread
in every woodworker's home.
Let's say 50 years ago, or a
century ago before power tools
really took off.
Unfortunately, today
a lot of wood shops,
you rarely see tools like this.
People forgot the
art of the hand tool.
And I got two different
types of tools here.
Where is this thing?
Here we go.
So on the upper left side,
because we're looking here too.
I got Japanese tools.
And recently, I found the
beauty of Japanese steel.
It's absolutely incredible.
Versus here on the lower right
side, these are western tools.
And here we got a
couple of planes.
Planes are used to shave wood.
They have a knife
embedded inside the tool,
and you push it across
the wood, and you can
get a very, very fine shaving.
This is how you remove
stock, and you can thickness
plates of wood this way.
Then you got some chisels
here that are Western chisels.
The main difference in quality
between the Western tools
and the Japanese tools
is in the steel itself.
The Japanese have a
long history of steel,
can imagine with samurais.
And the way they
make the finest tools
is by laminating a very,
very hard piece of steel
with a very soft piece of steel.
And the guys that
make these tools
do very much what I
do with the guitars.
There are people who've spent
their entire lives-- a lot
of times it's multiple
generations doing it--
just building tools by hand.
And these tools, now that
I've done this for so long,
I can really appreciate them
for their quality and incredible
performance.
So I don't want to say they're
better than the Western tools,
but there is much more of
a craftsmanship involved
in creating it.
The work.
Well, it's hand work,
for the most part.
So once you've thought through
the specs of the design
and you start building
it, you put stuff together
and then you cut it.
So here, I'm using
one of the knives,
and I'm shaving the
crest of the head.
Got to learn how to
sharpen the tools,
and then you got to learn
how to use them with control.
And one of the big
differences in the work,
let's say from sitting at
the computer and programming,
is there's no undo.
There's no let's revert
back to an old save.
So if you do a cut and you
overcut it, well, that's done.
And the amount of focus you need
to have when you do this work
is incredible.
You really got to be in the
zone when you're doing it.
So that's something that
I really enjoy about it.
The materials I
mentioned before then.
So the wood, and then
there's glue in the polish.
So the glue that I'd like
to use, which I think
is really the superior glue,
it's the most traditional glue.
It's called hide glue.
It's animal glue, basically.
It's cooked down
from hides and bones.
It's very similar to gelatin.
And the way you use
it is you melt it
in water in a special
glue pot that raises it
to a very specific temperature.
And when it's hot, you
can actually use it.
It's like honey.
And you can brush it on the
wood and very quickly you
got to put the joint, rub it,
and that's it, it's stuck.
The beauty of the glue is
that you can reverse it.
You can heat it up
later, open it up.
And the important
beauty of it is that it
crystallizes super hard.
It snaps like glass, so
it's incredible material.
The other material on the left
side is the polish that I use.
And this polish
is called shellac.
Shellac is a very
interesting material.
Used to be very popular maybe
a century ago, but today
largely forgotten.
Basically, it's interesting
to know its origins.
Comes from the seedlac
beetle in India
that grows on a specific tree.
And the beetle
encrusts the branches
of the tree with some
kind of excretion
from eating the
resins of the wood,
and lays its eggs in there,
forming its colonies this way.
The people there in India,
they flake this material off,
clean it from all the
bark and bug pieces,
and then you just
melt it in alcohol.
It's is organic as it gets.
And the process of applying
it-- French polish, which
I'll discuss later--
provides the finest finish
for acoustic instruments.
So it takes a lot more work to
do this polish than let's say,
spraying on lacquer, which
is what factories do.
But again, when we're
talking about building
something really,
really good, you
want to do the finest
possible thing.
So we go down to these
basic ingredients.
So one of my jobs is also
to find the best material.
So before starting
the guitar, I need
to have good
material, good wood.
You've got to start with good
wood to build good guitars.
And here's a picture of me
selecting wood in the Alps.
Me and my wife, I took her
on a very exciting trip
for two weeks to go
drive around the Alps
and visit people who
specialize in cutting
spruce trees specifically
for musical instruments.
And you've seen the pictures
here on the right side.
These are tops for violins
and cellos from spruce.
This is spruce, by the way.
You see the difference in
color from the cedar piece.
So we traveled, we looked
for the best material.
And once I found it,
here I'm selecting it,
I bought as much of
it as I could afford.
And the idea is to
stockpile your workshop
for your lifetime as a builder.
The longer it's in your
shop, and seasons, and ages,
the finer it's considered.
So I know my wife
loves me very much.
She sat on that
table for three days
while I was selecting
through thousands of pieces.
Let's start with
the construction.
So once I select, I
have the material,
I know what I'm going to
use to build a guitar.
I'm going to give you guys
a very, very quick overview
of basically every part of the
guitar, and how I build it.
So starting with the soundboard.
The soundboard starts
with a piece of wood
that's been book matched.
Which means you take it, and
you cut it down the center,
and you open it like a book.
And then you join it, which
means you shave it very,
very accurately and then
you glue it with hide glue,
of course.
And ideally, you have
no idea there's a seam.
It looks like a
single piece of wood.
Well, what it gives you is
a symmetric piece of wood--
or two pieces of
wood-- that are going
to react to humidity
changes exactly the same.
That gives you more stability
in the top of the instrument.
The back is treated
the same way.
Once we join the back, we're
going to start thicknessing it.
And in guitar
building, this is one
of the most
important things that
are going to determine
the overall sound
of the instrument.
There are machines today,
you can take a piece of wood
and run it through the
machine, and get it down
to exactly 2.22 millimeters,
or whatever thickness you want.
But the art of guitar
making-- or instrument
making in general-- is
to take a piece of wood
and appreciate its
unique properties.
Every piece of wood
is different, even
from the same log.
So I got stacks
of spruce billets,
and they're all marked
what tree they're from.
And a lot of them are from the
same tree, but a lot of them
have different properties.
The art of it is
really to understand
those different properties.
And you're shaving
it with the plane,
and you really
want to understand,
I got to shave a
little more here,
or leave it a
little thicker here.
You feel it with your fingers
a lot, bending the wood.
You can tap it.
And this is really important.
Because once you
thickness the soundboard,
you generally don't
want to touch it.
Once the soundboard
has been thicknessed,
the next step is to
cut the sound hole
and inlay the rosette.
So this is the sound hole
in the guitar right here.
Serves a very important purpose.
The sound of the
guitar doesn't come out
of the sound hole, which
is counter intuitive.
The sound hole serves the
purpose of allowing air
to come in and out.
Essentially, it's like a pump.
The sound comes
from the soundboard
here, which is moving when
you're playing the strings.
And this is causing
the air to move,
and that's what you're
hearing from here.
This is just allowing
this wood to not
create too much of a vacuum.
That's its purpose.
The purpose of the rosette is
to reinforce the sound hole.
And it can be done very simply
with a single piece of wood.
Or when you're looking at
very artistic, high level
instrument, this is really
the artistic signature
of the luthier.
And this is where handmade
really gets handmade.
So designing these rosettes,
you can spend a lot
of time and thought into it.
And when you know your guitars,
I can just look at a rosette
and know who built it.
Whose guitar that is.
So just to briefly
show you the process.
You start with the center motif.
They're little titles.
And each tile here has maybe
100 little squares of wood,
like pixels.
And you glue them around a
circle to get the design.
That's the center motif.
Once that's glued, you
dig different channels
for the borders.
And then you glue
in the borders.
The reason I do it in
different steps like that
is because the rosette is a
very complicated piece to inlay.
And I can say from research,
or just doing this,
I've learned to break
complicated procedures,
you break it down
to subtasks that
are a little less complicated.
And what that gives you is
a little bit more control,
and at the end, finer quality.
So you can see I'm
gluing it in here.
Here, I'm shaving the rosette.
And you can see the pixels
of a very close up photo
of the rosette there, the
little squares of wood.
And also, here's two
different designs.
It's really the artistic
side of the instrument.
You can play with many
different designs.
You can spend endless,
endless hours here.
It doesn't have any impact
on the sound of the guitar,
but this is part of the
artistic part of it.
So that's the rosette.
Once the rosette is finished,
I flip the sound board over,
and I start thinking about the
acoustics of the soundboard
of the guitar.
And this is where we start
constructing the guitar.
The soundboard is
supported with braces.
And Torres, it was done
sparsely before him,
but he's largely considered
the founder of this.
The fan bracing system, where
you take-- these are the fan
braces.
Sticks, basically,
made out of spruce.
You glue them onto
the soundboard.
And what it gives you is
a very controlled manner
in which the
soundboard vibrates.
Much more subtle but yet
important thing that it does
is actually, if
you carefully look
at the soundboard
of fine guitars,
they have a bit of
an arch to them.
And these braces actually
create that arch.
It's glued in a dome
dish called a solera.
And the gluing process, you
can see with these sticks.
The thin sticks that
are sticking vertically,
they're not the braces.
These are called go bars.
Go bars are the clamps.
They are sticks that are
basically bent, and flexed,
then they can be resting
against the ceiling.
And then, they can apply
very fine pressure--
let's say a couple
pounds-- directly down
in a single point.
So I can use a few of them to
glue each piece of wood down.
And I don't have to
deal with clamps.
It's a very
primitive method that
was actually developed by
harpsichord makers centuries
ago.
And it's a great method to use.
The fan braces,
once I glue them,
I shave them with a
little plane and chisels.
And again, this is done by hand.
You can try to come down
to precise dimensions,
but the best quality
usually comes
from some kind of intuition
you build in your fingers.
So where to stop, it's
a matter of gut feeling.
And that's how you see it here.
And here, I'm just flexing
and looking at the soundboard
to gauge how it's going
before I continue on
in the building process.
So the soundboard is by
far the most important part
of the guitar.
Selecting good wood,
the design, and then
finally the intuition of
the builder and to bring out
the qualities of
the wood are going
to have a huge factor in how
the instrument turns out.
The neck.
That's this part here on
the guitar, right here.
This is the neck,
and it starts out
with you saw that giant
piece of wood my workshop,
I was sawing it.
That is called Spanish
cedar, it could also
be done out of mahogany.
So I cut it from a
big billet, and then I
get it into a smaller
piece of wood,
and then I start shaving
it with the planes.
You see all these
shavings on my workbench.
The planes don't only
reduce the dimension,
but they make it
very, very flat.
And you cut special joints
to glue the head on.
And what's being glued on
here is called the heel block.
I'll show it in the next slide.
The heel block is one of
the big distinct features
between the Spanish
style of building
and the American style
of building guitars.
So you see that
big block of wood
here in the picture, which I
carve down later into what's
called the Spanish foot.
And the American style of
building doesn't have the foot.
What it has is you build
the body of the guitar,
and you build the
neck separately,
and later you join in
with a [? tendon. ?]
The Spanish style, you have
the Spanish foot, which
is integrated into the body.
You build the body of the
guitar around the neck.
So the sides are
actually slotted.
They're not glued into the neck,
they're just wedged into it.
And it's much more integrated.
And, I believe, for me
it's worked much better.
So this is the method I use.
So the photos aren't
exactly chronological.
Because here you see
the body, the guitar
that he built a little bit.
But the neck, just to show you
the finishing touches on it,
you got to carve it.
It started out as a
square piece of wood.
How do you carve it?
So this tool you see here
with the red handles,
it's called just a pull shave.
It's a knife with
two handles on it.
It's a great tool.
And you basically pull
it, and it gives you
a nice shaving of wood.
Of course, the skills
involved in using it
will determine whether you
destroy the guitar or not.
Initially, when you don't
know what you're doing,
you're going to be using
a lot of files, and rasps,
and sandpaper.
But as you get better
and better and better,
you can actually start using
more and more edge tools.
These are things that shave the
wood, and actually are faster,
and give you a much
higher quality finish.
So you can see how I do
some of that process here.
So let's talk about the
body of the guitar now.
The body of the guitar is
basically in this case,
I'm talking about the
sides and the back.
And in this photo, just like
this guitar, it's rosewood.
Rosewood is a dense, heavy wood.
Comes from all around the world.
You have it in Asia, India,
which is this material here.
south America, and Africa.
And you see the back
here and the sides.
The sides start out
as two strips of wood,
they're also book matched.
Everything in the
guitar is book matched.
So it starts out
as a single billet,
and it was sliced open so
that they're symmetric.
And the way they react to the
humidity will be symmetric.
And here I'm bracing the back.
I use the same go bar deck,
I use the hot hide glue.
You can actually see the pot of
glue here in one of the photos.
Let's see if you see that.
That's the hot pot.
And I use a syringe.
It's sitting in a
bath of water that's
heated to exactly 150 degrees
Fahrenheit right here.
Where is the light?
I can't-- there
it is right there.
And you can see the
glue squeezed out here.
The beauty of this glue is
after just a few seconds,
as soon as it cools
down, it gels.
It is like gelatin.
And you can take
a little scraper,
and just scrape it off.
And you get this nice
long kind of goomy worm.
And we used to have a dog, I
used to feed my dog this thing,
she loved it.
But now I have it
all over the shop.
So you brace it,
and you shave it.
And here you see me
bending the sides.
The traditional
method, of course,
is doing it on a hot pipe.
And you take the sides.
And when you apply heat
and pressure to wood,
if it's thin enough, it'll bend.
It plasticizes.
So sides that are around
two millimeters thick,
you can actually bend them.
Again, the skills
involved are to avoid
putting too much pressure, or
trying to do it too fast, which
will cause it to break.
Or if you do too slow,
the wood will burn.
It'll start smoking, and
you'll get charred wood,
which is very bad.
So back and sides.
A slight digression
here in this slide,
just because it is Google here.
So where did I use
some of my skills
with computers is in designing
a bending machine that
would bend the sides for me.
This is done in many
shops, it saves time.
The problem is that when
you bend it in a machine,
you usually use
a heating blanket
or some kind of heat source.
Whatever you do it in, when you
pull it out, it springs back.
So the idea is to over-bend
the shape of the sides.
So when you pull it out of
the mold of the machine,
it will spring back to the
final shape that you want.
So my idea was, I'll take
the shape of the sides,
and I'll over bend it by
a specific percentage.
So I wrote a small
program in MATLAB,
I entered the
coordinates of the sides
by hand, that
actually took the most
time to grit it out, and
measure that, and put that in.
And then I created a
program that'll basically
increase the angle
between each two vectors
by a certain percentage.
And you can see
here-- I can't see,
but there's the default
is on the bottom, that's
the original side shape.
And then increasing
it by 10%, 25%, 50%.
And then we jump up to
500%, and it gets very noisy
just because it was
measured by hand.
And the idea for me was to try
a few of these different curves
to see which one would give me
the closest shape when it comes
out of the bending machine.
Well unfortunately,
it turned out
that this was useless
because every piece of wood
reacts differently to the heat.
It springs back differently,
and basically the machine will
get you close, but not there.
So you always do it
by hand at the end.
It still saves time,
that's for sure.
But I did have an excuse
to program a little bit,
and I can show it here.
So here's the open guitar
before I grew the back on.
So you can see the
architecture of it.
It's actually quite interesting
if you're structural engineer
to understand to see
what's going on here.
A lot of it is structural.
There's very little
unnecessary pieces in here.
The fan bracing.
In this picture, you see
an additional brace here,
which is called the
treble bar right here.
It goes at an angle
across the fan braces.
What it does is it
breaks the symmetry
of braces, kind of forming
it more like a piano.
If you think of a piano, it has
different lengths of strings.
And this is the idea here.
To break the symmetry.
You see all these little
blocks of wood glued
around the perimeter here.
These are called tentalones.
And their purpose is to attach
the sides to the soundboard.
Each one, you pick it up with
a little needle, or tweezers.
You put a couple drops
of the hide glue,
and you stick it in there.
Hold it there for a few
seconds, and then you
go to the next one.
And it's actually
very meditative
to do this part of the process.
I really enjoy it.
And a lot of people
have never seen guitars
from the inside like this.
It's really beautiful.
And the next step of it, of
course, is to glue the back on.
So that's done like this.
This is a very
traditional method.
Roping the back.
So you basically
wrap rope around it.
I found that surgical tubing
works really good here,
so that's what I'm using.
And you can let it dry.
And once it's dry,
take off the rope,
and you have something
that looks like a guitar.
Doesn't sound like a
guitar yet, though.
Not even to me, as a builder
that can hear the wood.
That's going to come after
this step, the bindings.
The bindings are really, really
important for the guitar.
They serve a structural
purpose-- or functional
purpose, I should say--
that if you can see it,
it's a strip of wood
that's glued around all
the perimeter of the guitar.
It seals the end grain that
you see exposed on the back
and on the soundboard.
And this is very important
with wood to seal the end grain
so it doesn't react to changes
in the weather, and humidity,
specifically.
So the way they're done
is you carve a channel
around the corner perimeter
of the entire instrument.
There are two of them, actually.
There's the binding,
and then there's
the perfling, which
is slightly smaller.
And you bend them to
the shape of the guitar,
and then you glue them in there.
This is actually
quite a tedious,
a little more difficult part
in the process of building.
And you can see here
how I'm gluing them
in with a special roping method.
So I ran out of tape
one day, and this
was the method I was used
to, to just use tape.
It's very, very simple.
You just start at one end.
You put some glue, and you
tape it on, and you keep going.
But you need good tape,
you need strong tape.
And I couldn't get any, it would
take me awhile to order it.
So I built this jig which
allows me to use rope.
And it actually gave
me a lot more control,
and a lot more control on
the pressure to glue it on.
So you can see
how I'm roping it,
going from one end of the
instrument to the other.
And it just sits there
for a bit until it dries,
and then I can do the
other side of the guitar.
Once the bindings are
done, I can shave them,
and then I can finally hear
the quality of the instrument.
The reason for this
is that the bindings,
aside from sealing
the end grain,
they actually
change the stiffness
of the joints from
the sides to the back,
and the sides to the soundboard.
So they release some
of that tension there.
They open up the instrument.
And if you tap on
the soundboard,
you can finally hear the
instrument responding
in the way it's going
to be towards the end
of the build process.
So for me, this is one of
the most enjoyable steps.
Scraping to see the beauty.
You've got to cut
all these joints,
these are miters
here at the tail.
We're talking about
something that's
less than two millimeters wide.
And you get one shot at
cutting-- I can't see the red,
there it is- the miter
there with a chisel.
And if you mess it up, that's
how it's going to show.
There's not much
you can do about it.
So that's the bindings.
Once I'm past the
bindings, I have
a little bit of a breath out.
It's like, ooh,
that was hard work.
And we move on to nearly
finishing the instrument,
actually.
This is the fingerboard now.
There was a piece of ebony,
it's on the floor there.
I passed it around.
That's what the
fingerboard is made out of.
Yeah, it's the ebony.
This is the piece right here
where we glue it on the neck,
and the frets are going
to be installed in it.
And it needs to
be very hard wood
to take a lot of punishment
from the fingers.
So here I am starting to
plane the fingerboard,
and that took a me
some time to learn.
You need very good tools,
it's such hard, abrasive wood.
You really learn to
appreciate quality steel.
So it becomes a joy to work
once you have good tools.
So here you can see how
I'm gluing the fingerboard.
And once it's glued, I can
start slotting for the frets,
so I use a saw for that.
So the frets are spaced.
It's very carefully
determined, their location.
If they're not
accurately spaced,
you're going to have
problems with intonation,
and you'll never be
able to play in tune.
So it's critical to
get this part right.
And the frets
themselves are basically
pieces of nickel metal
with a tang on them.
You hammer them into the
slots, you cut them flush.
And then the detail
work is really
getting the leveling
of the frets down.
So they're not perfectly flat.
In really fine
instruments, you really
want to find a
very special bowing
in the relief for the frets.
And there is some
technical stuff
in the back buzzing
of the strings,
and the size of the
wave of the string,
depending on what
frequency it's on.
10 minutes?
You can keep going.
No, it's all good, thanks.
But here really, my
years as a player,
gave me a huge advantage.
Because I could really
appreciate an instrument
that was done right for
the playability of it,
meaning comfort.
You want to have
the strings as low
as possible without
exerting yourself too much.
And the way you achieve that
is by getting this part done
right.
So once the frets are done,
you can enjoy looking at them.
And you'll notice how
they're not spaced equally.
But rather, the space is
getting smaller, and smaller,
and smaller, and smaller.
So that's the
mathematical definition
of how to distance
for a 12-note scale.
And the last assembly
process is the bridge.
On the guitar, the bridge
is called the bridge
because it's bridging the
strings to the sound board.
It's going to
transfer the energy
of the vibrating strings,
and it's actually
a torque mechanism.
It's different from the
violin, or arch top guitars.
The way the bridge works
in the classical guitar
and acoustic guitars is
there's a big saddle here.
And the vibrating strings,
they pull on the bridge,
and they cause it
to move like this.
And imagine the
torque it applies
is this kind of movement
on the soundboard.
So it's not just this,
but this, more like this.
The heights, the
dimensions of the bridge
are very critical in the
overall resulting instrument.
So it is said that the
great Spanish makers used
to start with the
bridge, and build
the guitar around the bridge.
And you got to put
a lot of thought
into how the bridge is designed.
For example, the difference
between a classical guitar
bridge and a flamenco bridge.
The instrument might
be exactly the same,
but if I change the bridge,
it'll cause a big difference
in the sound.
So the bridge is made
out of a hard wood.
In this case,
Brazilian rosewood.
It's similar to Indian,
just a little bit denser.
I get to put my
flourish on there.
It's not redundant, though.
You need that up there.
It's called the tie
bar, because that's
where you tie the strings.
And if you see those two
strips of white there,
that's made out of bone.
That actually give
you that harness
which the strings would
eat through otherwise.
So you need bone there
to strengthen it.
Another little cute
innovation is done today.
I didn't invent this,
but I like to use it.
It's called a 12 hole bridge.
The 12 hole bridge allows
you to feed the strings
through the bridge,
and not to have
to loop back and tie
the string on itself,
which would raise the angle of
the string across the saddle.
It increases the torque
angle, or the break angle
on the saddle.
So especially with
flamenco guitars,
it's very important to do this.
All right.
So the bridge, you
got to design it,
the dimensions are important.
But the most important thing
is to measure its location.
If you don't glue it
in the right place,
you're going to be screwed,
because the guitar's never
going to be in tune.
So here you can
see measuring it.
The distance of it is going
to determine the scale
length of the instrument.
650 is the standard scale
for classical guitar.
You can play around with that.
640, 660.
Once you measure it and you know
exactly where it's going to be,
you glue it.
And I glue it with clamps.
I mentioned before,
there's a belly, or an arch
to the top of the guitar.
So the bridge is actually
built with that arch to it.
And when you glue
it, you want to make
sure you maintain that arch.
So underneath, inside
the soundboard,
there's a piece of wood with
that arch built into it.
And this is how
you the bridge on.
You can see it from a
different angle here.
And this is really the last part
of the assembly of the guitar.
And we're not done, because
now there's the French polish.
And a lot of times,
I will start a guitar
to build it and
finish making it,
and then I'll
start polishing it.
And by the time I
finish polishing it,
it'll be the same amount of
time as it took me to build it.
The French polish process is
very, very labor intensive,
takes an incredible
amount of time.
And basically,
it's the technique
of taking shellac which
has been melted in alcohol.
I described it comes from India
from the special beetle there.
And you see it in the
bottles here in the picture.
The materials are very simple.
It's shellac, you have a pad.
A pad is just a old
piece of cotton t-shirt
with some cheesecloth
wadded into it.
And then the other ingredients
are oil and more alcohol.
And those three
ingredients and the pad
are all you need to
do French polish.
The skills involved
take decades.
And I've been doing
this for over 15 years,
and it's still
something I see myself
learning for a long time.
It's one of the difficult
things to master.
It's almost never done
today in any woodwork shop
except for the finest restorers.
It was done in kings'
palaces to do fine furniture.
But acoustically, it
creates the finest finish
for the guitar in
the way it sounds.
The reason for that
is with the pad,
you're actually applying
thousands and thousands
of microscopically thin layers.
It creates a very thin
but hard layer of shellac
that's built on the guitar, and
it doesn't dampen the sound.
It actually makes it louder.
A lot of guitars that
are sprayed with lacquer
from factories, it's like taking
a nice vibrating piece of wood,
and then spraying
plastic over it.
And then that dampens the sound.
It doesn't sound as good.
So this is really the
reason to actually
invest in all that extra
hours of work to do this.
So here you can see a
guitar as I'm polishing it.
This here is called a
pounce bag of pumice.
Because the wood, if you
looked at it closely,
is full of little pores, and
you've got to fill them up.
So before the French
polish, the initial step
is to fill the pores.
And you rub pumice, it
abrades microscopic fibers.
And you feed them into the
pores until they're leveled.
Again, it's one of these things
that takes decades to master.
But the beauty
you get with it is
unparalleled with modern
finishes, I would say.
So I think I'm getting there.
So here's a finished guitar.
This guitar is a
little bit fancier.
For the perflings, I did
what's called herringbone,
or you can call it wheat pattern
going all around the perimeter.
And here's another
one that I did.
This guitar is built with
cypress for the body.
It's still a classical guitar,
it's much lighter, though.
It's more of a traditional
styled Torres guitar.
And it had a strip of
Brazilian Rosewood on the back.
Again, slightly more
ornamented for the perflings.
And now we have a little treat.
This is my friend, but
he's a great guitarist.
He's a client of mine.
Adam del Monte.
He's actually living
in Los Angeles.
He's a fantastic flamenco
player, and a fantastic
classical player.
It's very rare to
find someone that has
mastered both of these fields.
And he teaches down
there at USC and performs
all around the world.
If you get a chance to see him,
that'd be highly recommended.
I'm just going to play it,
ADAM DEL MONTE: Hi there
to everybody at Google.
My name is Adam Del Monte, and
I'm happily and proudly playing
two of Erez Perelman's guitars.
This one is a classical
guitar, and so it
is designed with warmth
and sweetness in mind.
And it's got plenty of it.
The sound just keeps sustaining.
It makes you drunk, because
every sound that you play,
you want to play another one.
That's the secret
of magical guitar.
As soon as you
play one note, you
don't get quite enough of it,
so you need to play another one.
And another one.
This is the sweetest
instrument I've ever played.
Expressive.
As opposed to this guitar,
which is a flamenco guitar.
And it is called a blanca,
because the back and sides are
made of cypress,
it is a white wood.
The top is also spruce, and
it is designed for speed.
So this would be your
Ferrari in the garage.
So it's designed to have
a very fast response.
It has a percussive sound.
And the magic about
this guitar is
that it just melts
into your fingers
and allows you to do
whatever you want.
Kind of like a Ferrari.
So Erez, you are the greatest.
Thank you.
EREZ PERELMAN: All right.
Yeah, that's Adam.
And that was the last slide.
I want to open up to Q&A now.
If anyone is interested, I have
a website with lots more info.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Please.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
You use the Japanese
chisels, but you
use Western planes, which are
pushed rather than pulled.
And I just wondered if
you tried the pulling one,
and if there's a difference
in the woodworking style.
EREZ PERELMAN: Yeah, I
have Japanese planes, too.
They're a little more
finicky to set up,
there's no adjusting
rings on them, or screws.
But the steel is
definitely superior,
but it comes down to the
tool that does the job best.
And I find the Western
style adjustments allows
me to get there with planing.
With the chisels, it's
a different story.
I want an edge that's going
to hold as long as possible.
So I like to use the
Japanese chisels there.
I have Western chisels that
are great, too, depending
on the wood I'm cutting.
A lot of the tools are
specific for a single thing
that I'm going to use them on.
So it's really
finding what it's for,
and then learning how to
do it the best way there.
AUDIENCE: So as a past
life as a researcher,
you probably spent a
lot of time thinking
about how to do new
things in new ways.
Have you thought about new ways
to do bracing, or double tops,
and all sorts of
stuff like that?
EREZ PERELMAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So it's interesting.
When I first started
building guitar,
I was convinced I'm going to
invent the best guitar that
was ever built. And I thought
about it for a long time,
and I came up with this crazy
design called the prison
guitar.
And it was crazy, it was insane.
It turned out beautiful,
but after years, and years,
and years, I realized respecting
the tradition, the centuries
that people tried different
things and what survived,
there's a lot of things
to learn from that.
Today, there are double tops.
Double tops are guitars that are
designed with volume in mind.
Basically, you take
the soundboard,
which is a two millimeter
thick piece of wood.
And how do you make
it even lighter?
So what they do is they
hollow it out and stick
something synthetic, it's called
Nomex, in a honeycomb fashion.
This is coming from aeronautical
and space engineering.
You can cut that the weight by
half, get a much louder guitar.
And I've done it, I've
experimented with that.
But I believe the
quality of sound
is compromised with
that kind of guitar.
I'm a very strong
believer in the solid wood
traditional style of instrument.
I do I have two
pictures here, though,
to show some innovation
that has been
done with traditional guitars.
These are still
traditional guitars.
So on the left, you see a
guitar with a hole in the side.
It's crazy, but it's very
popular today amongst players.
It's called a sound port.
What it does is it gives the
player a bit of that sound.
It's throwing it in their face.
And this is especially
important for people
who are playing with a
big orchestra behind them,
or if you're playing
with an accompaniment.
A few people.
And then you really
want to hear yourself,
so this really gives
you that ability.
Additionally, it's hard
to make out in that photo.
It's an elevated fingerboard.
The fingerboard is raised
above the sound board
to give you a lot more
access to the higher notes.
It makes it an
ergonomic feature,
more comfortable
to play up high.
The guitar you see on the right
side is a incredible guitar,
it's called a Brahms guitar.
One of my favorite players
ever is called Paul Galbraith.
And he developed this guitar
with the late luthier David
Rubio from England.
It's essentially
a guitar that has
fanned frets where every string
has a different scale length.
If you notice that the bridge
and the nut are different
angles.
So the bass and the trebles
have different lengths.
And I had to write a
program to compute the scale
lengths on this guitar, too.
What's incredible and special
about this instrument,
normally when you have more
than six strings on a guitar,
it's extra basses.
So you add basses, basses,
basses, and it's very easy
to control them with the thumb.
It doesn't open up a lot of
the range of the instrument.
On this guitar, you
actually add a treble.
So there's one extra
treble, and one extra bass.
So it's opening it
up from both sides.
It opens up a whole
new body of music
that couldn't be played on the
guitar before to be played.
It is a difficult
instrument to play.
You play it upright
like a cello,
it has an end pin that
goes in the floor.
So to answer your
question, there
is experimentation
within tradition.
And today, I continue
experimenting.
But my experiments
are much more focused
on tenth of a millimeter thing.
Very, very fine adjustments.
Where I'm looking for something
very consistent, but to improve
it and finding
which way to wiggle
the curve to achieve finer
and finer instruments.
Also to a lesser extent,
but just as important,
I have clients
with special needs.
For example, clients
that have injuries
in their backs or shoulders.
And one of them asked for
an adjustable support system
with a guitar that
could lay on the floor,
and could be angled and
raised to any angles.
You can even stand with it.
So here I built him
a special support
system out of a monopod.
Basically like a camera monopod.
And that's one of the
benefits of-- you're
building every guitar
for the client,
and it might encompass something
like this in the support
systems, too, specifically
for their needs.
I don't do a cookie
cutter approach
where everything is exactly
the same, take it or leave it.
So it's a very feedback
oriented process.
And the research is done within
a very controlled manner.
AUDIENCE: Did you get a
chance to look at the work
that Adrian Houtsma
did-- like in 1975,
80-- on guitar acoustics?
EREZ PERELMAN: The
name sounds familiar.
I used to read a lot of
the-- is it GAO publications?
Did he do the round bracing?
The circle bracing?
AUDIENCE: The bridge support.
EREZ PERELMAN: Bridge support.
AUDIENCE: It was
basically, you can
make the face a
little thinner if you
prevent the bridge from rotating
with a separate support.
EREZ PERELMAN: Yeah.
Specifically, no, I don't
remember his research.
But every builder
researches to some extent.
A lot more here in
America, for some reason.
It's the land of cowboys here.
And it's very interesting to
see what people are doing.
Again, I'm a very strong
proponent of the traditional
build, for the special reason
that I had the opportunity
to play those guitars
made by Torres.
This is a very rare opportunity.
If anyone plays guitar
here and they have a chance
to play a historic instrument,
the sound is really magical.
And it's impossible to
portray it on recording.
You really have to try
it out to appreciate it.
So I'm open minded, I'm
always considering new things.
But to me, the
ideal sound is still
coming from that
traditional design.
And I'll always look for better.
But right now, that's
the ideal for me.
AUDIENCE: If it's public,
how many instruments
do you build it every year?
EREZ PERELMAN: Sure,
it's very limited.
Each guitar takes me
over a month to build.
So I'm building around
10 to 12 guitars.
And this is generally the
output of luthiers doing guitars
at the top level without trying
to expand and scale the shop
with helpers, or big machines.
So I'm not trying to
build more guitars,
I'm trying to improve
the quality of each one.
And the French
polish, as I said,
that takes a huge amount of
time in the build process.
So that limits how many
guitars you can make.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you guys.